Kylie Jenner and Tyga gets steamy while  Kim Kardashian helps her brother Rob get  ready to be a dad  Kylie and Tyga are featured in Alexander  Wang's new campaign video posted on  their Instagram accounts it shows the  two walking hand-in-hand into a party  DJed by Skrillex  Tyga pins Kylie up against a wall and  kisses her neck and things continue to  heat up later the two head to the  bathroom and Tyga sits in the bathtub  and watches his 19 year old girlfriend  seductively dance with blonde model and  at yours and while Kylie's busy  promoting the Wayne gang on Sunday's  episode of robbing Chyna sister Kim is  busy helping Rob prepare for fatherhood  by teaching him how to swaddle a baby  let me try some skills on the bottle on  the bottom stick the head out nothing  will really prepare you for this  you got a Do It Yourself yeah I'll be  good